i don't think people understand when
something comes along that changes the
world the internet changed everything
[Music]
you're back with the questions and i'm
back with the answers
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to the
askgaryvee
show episode 333 as we are now here in
2022. my marion seth is going to ask the
questions this is an nft edition
first i just want to say thank you to
everybody
for all the interactions the dms the
comments the
incredible amount of chatter in the v
friends discord on twitter these days
instagram dms tick tock and everything
else the community of the 212 931 5731
text platform it just feels incredibly
special to be
at the halfway point of my life and be
in this place and obviously the nft
thing so many questions and i thought
you know what it's time to bring back
the askgaryvee show anyway except the
last time we did it was february 2020
so two years so we're looking to get
this back regularly so let's
get into the show chris liner asks would
you treat minting a project the same way
as you would with content creation just
do it even if it isn't fancy with
hostage lighting if that's what it takes
or would you be more methodical that's a
great question you know v-friends
famously gets [ __ ] on because my art
doodling skills are not
what people consider phenomenal i argue
that andy warhol and jackson pollock
were considered [ __ ] too and that the
storytelling and the narrative art is in
the eye of the beholder you know the
standards of the projects that are
coming out right now are incredibly
beautiful both from one of one artists
and
incredible graphic designers in the web
three realm
on the generative and non-generative
projects there's these different
projects that are not just like a
beautiful image of an animal
with like just rad they're just unique
they're a little bit different you can
win on stick figures you can win on dots
damien hurst is dots i think what
matters is you can't think of nft
projects the way of social media because
an nft project is the thing i think of v
friends like i think of gary vee
not the way i think of a single post on
tick tock this is your whole reputation
on the line like what are you gonna
abandon when it didn't do well so for
all the people that paid 500 bucks for
an nft and now it's zero you're just
going to go on to the next thing that's
very different than putting out a piece
of content that might have not done well
that didn't cost anything to anybody on
the other side i'm in a really tough
spot now people are paying hundreds of
thousands of dollars on the secondary
market i feel pressure
i'm going to spend the next 45 years of
my career trying to make sure there's
demand on these original tokens
so
yes you should just do it
but you should do it because you want to
do it for the next decade make it your
sesame street make it your pokemon make
it your hello kitty make it your cabbage
match kid make it your raggedy ann those
are all super iconic things like make an
nft project your life's work and watch
it pay you back tenfold
excuse me
so
yes and no
sorry guys
go ahead keep that in no editing jason
landry asks so the question is how does
one invest in the nft space without
buying images that you've said will
eventually go to zero well look i'm
incredibly concerned that 98 of projects
are going to zero so how do you do that
you don't know i don't know i've bought
many collectibles that haven't done it
well and i've got a good track record of
doing well my good track record is i
wait for 30 or 60 days to watch
something or sometimes two three years i
watch sports cards for a year before i
decided to say i think it's about to
explode so
i think that you have to watch things i
think too many people try to mint
at the lowest cost but then you're
completely gambling
whereas if you watch something for a
month or two and you go into the discord
you go into the twitter you follow the
founders religiously and see what she or
he is up to
are they like can you get a sense
intuition that they're about this life
that this is what they're gonna do
then you can kind of go all in it's a
guessing game on mint
how to buy one
i think watching the market and jumping
in and paying double or triple the mint
aka to put in us dollars instead of
ethereum paying 900 bucks instead of 300
bucks but you've seen the steam you see
the passion in the community you see
they're not there to just flip they want
to hold they want to be part of the
narrative of developing this lizard or
this unicorn or the wizards or the game
or the small brains like if they're
there for it you see what we call
diamond hands there's people there to
hold not to just flip because then
you're just stuck if everyone's there to
flip well then it can collapse like
beanie babies but if it's iconic like
stuffed stuffed animals stiff bears for
hundreds of years so you've got to look
for people buy a stiff
to put on their shelf
and look at for 50 years people bought
beanie babies because they thought
they'd buy for five and sell for 15.
right now that's what's happening in nft
land which is why so many are going to
collapse the only way to avoid that is
to watch the people that are in it for
life
i'm in it for life and i think others
are too and that's why i'm looking for
it starstriker asks what do you think is
the biggest weakness in the nft space
right now and in the near future i think
the biggest weaknesses is greed
i mean we used to talk about providence
in this space we used to talk about you
know like how it would change
you know the way we interacted
but right now it's just a complete
tornado of day trading
what happened with internet stocks at
first we're like the internet and like
internet companies were evaluated very
specifically and then everybody started
day trading because the internet came
out itself and internet stocks were
there
and that's because they were trading on
it without fundamentals right now we
have people
buying
20 000
pictures that they own i don't think
it's right click and save and all that
[ __ ] they own it the problem is i
don't think the founders are going to be
able to keep up demand for 20 years
unless they'll go down and i think
that's 98 of the projects the biggest
vulnerability is greed and lack of
creativity everybody saw board ape and
punks and just copied it now it's
laughing llama and
silly
swans and
charming chairs and so listen [ __ ]
there'll be a ton of carnage the [ __ ]
will hit the van and i'll get blamed and
i'm gonna be like [ __ ] man i made a
hundred trillion videos saying 98 gonna
fail this is internet stocks and i'll
still get blame c garyvee he was a
scammer who's a fad it's not
nfts are here forever for the rest of my
life i will die and they'll still be a
major factor in our society just like
the internet
because they're functional they're
contracts there's so much you can do
with it
but the supply of garbage is real
and the cost of entry is low and i think
that's a factor ry underscore z asks i
resell for a living mostly on ebay
sports cards pokemon cards and different
types of media how can i leverage
blockchain technology and add nfts into
my business soon i believe that people
are going to take physical goods
ship them
to a secure place and get an nft that
represents it and sell the nft that
represents the ownership just like
my stock scroll it up those are big
pieces of paper that represents my
stock in a company the merc style
exchange like like we're going to get
into a place this is why people are
underestimating nfts nfts
are incredible technologies so my friend
you're going to be able to eventually
ship your stuff to a place the physical
stuff
and then sell the nft that represents it
and next person is going to own it
and they could claim it they could say
send it in cash it in i'm taking my nft
send me the thing the comic book the
sports card but like this is gonna be on
the blockchain
like this is gonna be on the blockchain
like
this is gonna be on the blockchain
like it's gonna be in a secure place
just like the art is in morocco just
like those armored cars just like the
stock certificates like
people are missing the point just learn
about this blockchain learn about what
nfts as a whole mean whether ethereum
wins whether solana wins the macro
concept it didn't matter that ask jeeves
failed
seth used google today
got it
that's it seth you use the search engine
if i was doing this show in 95 i
couldn't tell you which search engine
was going to win i would have said yahoo
the way you can do it is by learning
how to trade nfts now which will prepare
you when you actually are taking your
physical goods and then ft'ing them you
like that
how cool is that
right that's my twitter stock
it's my story
that's it all of ebay as we know it is
going to be that because there's no
fraud you know [ __ ] up and how hard it
is to sell [ __ ] in the internet getting
paid they cancel it shipping it
no
people don't see the chess moves as much
as sold on ebay with no friction just
click click click the click it compounds
the volume
you know many people have tons of good
[ __ ] in their house that they don't want
to sell on ebay because it's hard
but if it's just an nft
and in 20 years companies are going to
come to your house and just take all
your [ __ ] and send it to their place you
know when people buy on ebay just to
resell on ebay because somebody [ __ ]
up and sold it too cheap so i'm just
going to buy the nft sit on it and
relist it
somebody bought a [ __ ] gary b today
on v friends released and sold in three
hours made it 10 to eat made 35 000 it's
gonna happen to everything in the world
physical and digital the blockchain
fixes a lot of the inefficiencies of the
world just like the credit card came
along and fixed cash but all the 80 year
olds watching right now like yeah we
didn't want the credit card now 35 year
olds are like no credit card are you
[ __ ] idiot the same way these 40 year
olds that are watching around saying no
way nfts
like that's how i view them they're if
you're 40 and you're like no way nfts
you don't realize the technology matters
so much that you're just your
grandfather 50 years ago saying i'll
never use a credit card
and then does i don't think people
understand when something comes along
that changes the world the internet
changed everything
the blockchain changes everything which
blockchains ethereum solana i don't know
which projects board aid the friends
cool cats alien friends world of women i
don't know
i just know
that the same way i was a great investor
in web 2.0 because i have great people
skills and understand who's got it
that's why i think i'll be a good
investor and as far as me well i'm
[ __ ] me brian collins asks how do you
find smaller projects that actually have
potential to be a long-term play in not
a cash grab
i spend enormous amounts of time on
twitter and discord and i guess you know
i'm gonna place my career as garyvee
i can dm the creator and be like hey can
you get on zoom for 15 minutes and i
could talk to them and i did two of
those yesterday and one i'll never
invest in and the other one i might
intuition doing the investing you know
but for everybody who's watching you got
to take some chances play with money you
can't afford to lose play taste but what
i told you is a big one too many people
guess on mint
watching for a month and seeing that
something tripled but it's still 900
bucks not 300 bucks but there's some
good action there those are good
projects to get into
nevser8 asks how should we take
advantage of this moment when we're
early in the nft space before 99 of the
world joins being thoughtful this is
internet 95 6789
so don't get crazy don't be a gambler
be a strategist but lean into
self-awareness you might not be good at
running a project but you might be good
at pr so why don't you start doing pr
for the best projects look at guy osiri
one of the greatest managers of all time
madonna u2 what did he do he didn't
launch a project
he manages board ape brilliant i'm an
operator i build big [ __ ] companies
no big vayner x's now
wine library empathy crush like this is
what i do v friends i build companies so
i'm gonna operate but you might be a
designer
and you know that you can design rad
[ __ ] but you need to find a partner
who's a promoter to create demand how
many artists are hitting me up like what
do i do gary i'm like you create demand
they're like i don't know how like
that's why there used to be and there
still is and there should be
you know art galleries they create the
demand that's why you give up 50 of your
action to them
all these people are like ah i'm gonna
keep all the action i'm like you don't
know how to create demand and so what do
you do you're gonna pay some influencers
to tweet
some folks are losing their [ __ ]
reputations behind the scenes
couldn't pay me 40 trillion dollars to
promote a [ __ ] project crypto
wasteland asks what are some utilities
that you'd like to see projects provide
their holders in the coming years
everything free physical goods instead
of just free nfts right kind of like
what i'm doing with gift goat access to
parties percentages of their of
royalties and other things like you can
do anything they're just
they're just contracts you know i've
thought about buying an island and
calling it the friends island
like richard branson thing and if you're
a viewfriend soldier you can come and if
not you can't
that's cool you can do anything look at
what i'm doing you know fly fish club
the token is the membership club you
used to pay 12 000 a month for one-time
fee and then monthly fees for a country
club but now it's a token
so now you can go
enjoy it maybe you move and you sell it
for a profit it's an asset
people are underestimating the
technology you are underestimating
technology it's not right click and save
i can make pretend i own this building i
own this building i take a picture more
people fake on pictures than you want
blockchain you're underestimating
technology because you're in a point in
your life right now where you just don't
want to do the 50 hours of homework and
i respect that and you don't have to i
underestimate technologies all the time
but if you're watching this show
you probably
are either curious or in it and
continued homework education is what's
going to get you to where you need to go
to
but me included and everybody else at
tiffy tops this game we are all
underestimating this as right as i was
about the internet i underestimated it i
definitely didn't think in 1995
that i would press a button on a mobile
device and have a car sitting there for
me in two seconds or just a minute i
didn't see people renting out their
houses instead of hotels when big
technologies come
crazy [ __ ] happens
crazy shits about happen
for the cynics your points are well
taken too much greed
too much short behavior people are gonna
get smashed like they did on beanie
babies beanie babies getting smashed
doesn't mean that stuffed animals got
smashed it's one of the biggest
economies in the like
going it's insane how much success
stuffed animals have in our society
and so the next one comes along nfts are
stuffed animals
the individual projects
time will tell
on who's going to win but i hope there's
a lot of people out there like me that
realize that's the first question
if you fail
your reputation is ruined forever and if
that's not a motivator i don't know what
the [ __ ] is thanks for listening and
watching to askgaryvee episode 333 334
is gonna be soon because i'm back and
doing this i know i've been doing a ton
of nft stuff since it's new year we'll
do some
other stuff look for my twitter where i
tweet out the questions that is where we
do it you ask the questions on twitter
we bring it in seth asks it
and we [ __ ] answer it askgaryvee show
33 in the bag
[Music]
you